sex and drugs and rock and roll I mean
these things seem to be pretty
intimately linked in other words
acoustical driving sexual license and
pharmacological disruption of ordinary
brain states this is what religion was
about for the first couple of million
years and then you know B di D UNIX got
ahold of it
weasels I mean people you wouldn't leave
alone with your chickens to ashari and
have been in charge ever since is always
communal it's always it's not solitary
and it seems like the technological
revolution is lots of solitary efforts
sitting in a computer screen sitting at
home watching TV
putting earphones on with your Walkman
all that stuff seems to be more of the
great barrier to life well it's a
barrier to physical community but some
people might argue you know that a
virtual community is coming into
existence I'm not that keen to make that
point I do think that any any activity
that you can participate in that does
not involve matters is a good thing so
it's better to access the well than to
drive 60 miles to see a friend but I'm
not an enthusiast of teledildonics and
some of the more exotic technological
sexual schemes that have been cooked up
the electronic network the ultimate
effect of all this electronic technology
I think is to encourage diversity I
think that you know this is a favorite
beef of mine but I I think that profits
people to go back and read Marshall
McLuhan that McLuhan was never
assimilated he was simply dismissed at
the same time that psychedelic drugs
were suppressed McLuhan ceased to be
ever mentioned in the Academy and that
he very very brilliantly explained the
impact of media on cultural dynamics and
by media we mean any technology from the
screwdriver to LSD technologies change
the societies that use them always in
ways that the society cannot anticipate
and expect and so I think computers are
really driving a lot of this archaic
tribalism I mean obviously in a world
with epidemics socially transmitted and
sexually transmitted diseases and stuff
like that we can't return to the simple
orgy around the campfire of 20,000 years
ago and yet we need to do something
operationally equivalent to that well
the electronic media may throw open an
opportunity for that I don't know I
don't pretend to understand I mean like
for instance my normal reaction to
gratuitous violence in media is to
deplore it like everybody else does on
the other hand I've never had to bash
somebody's brains out in fury and it may
be because I've seen a lot of that done
for me on celluloid and so it has in
some sense deep potentiated the need for
violence in other words maybe vicarious
violence is bad is the is as d violent
as we can be if you know the
primatologists talk about this goes back
to the sexual thing again
pansies that never witness other
chimpanzees having sex never get it
together they masturbate their way
through life male chimpanzees that have
never seen the sex act can't get it
together well so then what do we do we
inveigh against pornography stigmatize
it and it has to be hidden away and yet
you know probably the consequence of so
much softcore and hardcore pornography
on cable television is probably a
measurable increase in the amount of
pleasure and non neurotic sex that
people are having because they finally
saw what was permitted you know or got
an idea of what was permitted and said
my god you can do that and you can do
that and you can do that well let's get
to it
[Music]
well like I say I don't I don't feel
strongly about these things I think
they're interesting questions how media
affects us and what's good and what's
bad
everything is very double-edged you know
I mean take a concept like free trade
sounds good free trade is a license for
cultural murder and genocide free trade
means I can sell crap anywhere it means
you know farewell rug makers of
Tajikistan pottery makers of the upper
Amazon crapola is headed your way and
don't try to stop it
everything had you know you can't figure
out until you figure out what goals
you're trying to maximize you don't know
whether you want more violence in the
movies or less violence in the movies or
more sex on cable TV or less or or what
you're trying to do I believe firmly in
in the power of the imagination and in
the wisdom of the situation thank God
I mean imagine how despairing one would
be if they believed that the solution to
our problems rested in highly trained
executives implementing the correct
policies I mean my god it means we're up
[ __ ] creek without a paddle
but what the psychedelics reveal is a
dynamic on a scale where and they just
basically say do not worry act commit
but don't radiate anxiety because it's
just ridiculous
to radiate anxiety to do vitiates energy
and some kind of plan is happening every
situation that has been put in place on
this planet from the very beginning has
been eventually swapped out for
something else and you know we worry
about the impact of human civilization
but a asteroids smashing down on this
planet in a fraction of a second could
do more damage by orders of magnitude
than 50 thousand years of human
technology and pollution so it's very
interesting to try and build an ethic or
a point of view when you expand your
premises to try and actually encompass
that the real dynamic of the planet
Arian cosmic environment which is
unpredictable shifting will hold
- beyond rational apprehension large
thing
[Music]